your doctor may obtain a skin biopsy to
view the tissue under a microscope and
make a diagnosis of your condition the
skin is the largest organ of the body
and is responsible for regulating body
temperature sensing painful and
pleasurable stimuli providing a
protective barrier against bacterial
toxins and extreme temperatures and
maintaining a balance of water and
electrolytes by preventing internal
fluid evaporation skin consists of three
layers the epidermis dermis and
hypodermis the epidermis helps prevent
most bacteria and other foreign
substances from entering the body the
dermis provides support for the
epidermis and gives the skin its
flexibility and strength the hypodermis
is a layer of fat cells providing
insulation and protective padding skin
biopsies are commonly ordered for warts
and moles skin cancers and other growths
allergic reactions bacterial or fungal
infections acne psoriasis and injuries
and scarring for all skin biopsy
procedures your doctor will inject your
skin with a local anesthesia to numb the
area shave biopsies are usually
performed on surface lesions during this
procedure your doctor will use a sharp
scalpel or razor blade to thinly slice
or shave the top layer of the skin
lesion this type of biopsy does not
require stitches doctors usually perform
a punch biopsy for deeper skin lesions
your doctor will rotate a circular
hollow blade around the lesion until it
cuts completely through the epidermis
and dermis he or she will remove a small
cylinder of skin usually smaller than
the size of a pencil eraser containing
all layers of the skin and lesion
depending on the size of the sample the
area may or may not be closed with
stitches an excisional biopsy is larger
and deeper than a shave or punch biopsy
it is used for conditions such as cancer
which must be entirely removed your
doctor will go as deep as is necessary
to remove all of the area visibly
affected as well as some unaffected
tissue around the outside of the lesion
the incision is then closed with
stitches
after the biopsy you will need to keep
the area dry and cover it with a sterile
bandage or gauze dressing for one to two
days
antibiotic ointment should be applied
until it is completely healed
acetaminophen or ibuprofen can be taken
for any discomfort at the biopsy site